today i just wanted to share with you
like my multi-year saga
of repairing my commodore 64 that i
found in the basement of the thrift
store
buried in the dust and dirt and
just my experience of going from someone
who had some
basic working knowledge of playing
around with electronics
and someone who maybe has a little bit
better of an understanding and
appreciation for how these machines
worked
so let's uh talk about the commodore 64.
uh for those who haven't used one before
um it might be a little unfamiliar
um this computer was released in 1982.
it sold about 10 to 17 million units
depending on who you
ask and that puts it among the ranks of
like the top
selling computers of all time i think um
so when you turn this thing on you just
get this screen
and this is like a screen that
represents a world of like infinite
possibilities
uh what you're looking at right here is
an interpreter where you can just start
typing in
basic code like you the most common one
is the
10 print go to tend uh you know hello
world kind of thing
you can just start going now you can
also plug in cartridges in the back
there's a flop floppy disk attachment
that you could use to load additional
software
and i'm sure there were many many users
who
never wrote a line of code or you know
never created their own applications
but use the software created by others
and that's perfectly fine that's
perfectly great
but for those who wanted to learn the
system a little bit better
commodore provided a programmer's
reference guide and this guide
would basically explain to you like at a
really low level how all the hardware
worked
and if you found that this game that you
wrote or the software that you wrote in
basic wasn't fast enough
well their programmers reference guides
would also teach you how to write
assembly code
and so instead of using an interpreted
language you could
write assembly and get
that so much more performance and
interact directly with the graphics
hardware on the system
and really like a whole generation of
programmers
you know grew up with this machine and
it changed the course of their lives
um and so why do i want one of these
uh or why did i want one of these i'm
not quite sure
um i was a little young to have ever
like used a commodore 64 in its heyday
but i knew that it existed and i
especially knew that it existed by way
of the demo scene which is a really
fascinating
internet art subculture that i i just
really love
and a lot of folks in the demo scene
also love this system so
i kind of wanted one too uh also i had
spent some time
uh studying like the architecture of the
nintendo entertainment system and
learning how that worked at a really
low level and that was a really rich and
rewarding experience
and so i kind of wanted to do the same
thing with the commodore 64 because they
share this very similar processors and
i thought it would be interesting to
compare and contrast how engineers
you know took like the same like similar
building blocks but created
like vastly different systems
and so if you look at these old
computers
and you compare them to computers of
modern times uh
it's clear to see that everything has
gotten smaller
everything has gotten more tightly
integrated
and the way that we think about fixing
these old computers versus fixing
new computers is also drastically
different on the left here you see an
actual
photograph of my board you can see that
two chips are removed
because i was debugging and trying to
determine faulty chips
and so i was able to do that with
relative ease and
on the right you see a macbook pro
16 inch model and wow that just looks
so crazy i don't know if i would ever
try and fix a specific component on that
thing
and i don't think most people do
certainly uh apple you know has some
sort of refurbishment center and i don't
really know how that works
but your average like mom and pop
computer repair shop
probably would throw their hands up at
this um
now there are some exceptions to this
rule uh a fellow by the name of louis
rossman
uh based in manhattan runs a computer
repair shop
and he is like a wizard uh he uses
advanced micro soldering techniques
you know under a microscope uh and he'll
he'll debug
and he'll replace like the missing
components and repair traces and it's
crazy
but most people aren't gonna do that
if you look at a commodore 64
uh you you would notice that a lot of
the chips and a lot of components on
there are bog standard
off the shelf and
it was possible for people back back
then
to repair their own computers they could
buy these replacement
chips um you know there's tons of 74 000
series logic which is like a de facto
standard
of the of the time and there's
off the shelf dram chips so if you're
ram chip fried you could
you know luck if you're lucky it was
socketed and so you just
pluck it out uh if you're a little less
lucky you'd
probably have to wrestle with a solder
sucker or if you're
you know maybe a little bit more wealthy
uh
today like you can use a desoldering gun
which kind of automates the process of
removing chips from boards
um and it's really important to note
that
even back in the 80s commodore provided
schematics
to authorize like warranty centers and
also just their customers
if you opened up the programmer's
reference guide that i mentioned earlier
you could fold out you would see
a folded up schematic that you could
unwrap and you would see how your
computer was built
uh imagine getting one of those now with
your laptop
uh you'd be overwhelmed and i was
overwhelmed looking at this schematic
uh when i got started um it's just
you know an insane amount of detail um
and you if you were you know
trying to fix your computer back in the
day if you were lucky one of those
standard tips failed
but if you're a little more unlucky
maybe one of the
uh custom parts failed and that was kind
of
like your sign that you need to send
this off to an authorized warranty
center and you know let them use their
stock of like
proprietary chips to repair your system
today we don't really have the luxury of
buying new
commodore 65 10 i think this chip number
for the cpu
uh you'd have to harvest them from some
other
broken machine if and hope that one
works
so lucky for us in the year 2020
information has been preserved and it's
being shared online
and i think anybody who ever tries to
repair a commodore 64 will stumble upon
this individual's website which is just
a
gold mine of information this uh ray
carlson
uh i believe was a former commodore
repair tech
and he has accumulated over the years uh
tons of documentation
tons of reference material and it's
super
critical and super useful for someone
like me
who is just getting started to be able
to rely
on the accumulated experience of someone
like him
and it's just amazing to me that he has
documented this so thoroughly
and sharing it for free so
this is all well and good and
if you are experienced you can sift
through this information and you know
what to look for
but i wasn't really experienced when i
started out
when i got my commodore 64 in the thrift
shop it looked like this looked like in
pretty good condition
um but when i turned it on
i was i was greeted with not a very
friendly screen
you might notice that this looks nothing
like that friendly blue screen that we
saw earlier
uh i did not dare use a video clip for
this presentation
but if this were a video you would see
these colored dots
wiggling and waving across the screen
and the computer was
totally unusable
but that didn't stop me from trying to
fix it i took apart
my the computer that's a thing that i
kind of always do when i get old
electronics
i like to clean them up i like to make
them presentable
because i also want to use them they're
not just sitting on the shelf
i mean they sometimes shouldn't sit on
the shelf for a little while
but every now and then i like to pick
them up and use them so here's what my
actual commodore 64 looks like when you
take it out of the case
um for a beginner like this is
scary what are all these chips on the
board
what do they mean how do they interact
and
i used rey's documentation and
i started you know trying to get a sense
for like what's
what's wrong with this like what part
has failed what parts have failed
i was completely you know fumbling
around in the dark
um you can see here that
rey lists all of various chips
and like their failure mode what does it
look like when this chip fails
and all i knew was that i had a black
screen with dots on it
he calls them blank screens and surprise
surprise there are
lots of blank screens i
was overloaded with information
i did not know what was important what
was not important
but i still tried i went through chip by
chip and tried to replace some things
um one common thing that people
recommend is piggybacking
ram basically just taking a replacement
ram trip and sticking it on top of
one that you think might be working and
i did that and of course that didn't
work
um the sound chip is notorious for
failing on the commodore 64. it's known
as the sid
you might have heard of it um and
sometimes when that ship fails it
prevents the whole system from booting
up
so i plucked that out no luck there's
another chip that fails a lot it's
called the pla
the pla is kind of like a switchboard
operator for the system
and if that ship fails then nothing will
work
so i bought a replacement pla from
germany by some guy
and that didn't work either so
i was just out of ideas i decided to
set this project down and you know maybe
come back to it when
i could attack the problem with a little
bit more rigor what i was doing was akin
to
you know if you had a programming
project that you're working on and there
was a bug
i was basically just changing random
things and hoping that something would
work
and just like that's no way to program
that's not really a great way to
diagnose
a piece of hardware that's faulty
so i spent some time
working on other projects i kind of
upgraded my tools a little bit
i gained a better understanding for how
they worked and a few years later i
decided to come back to this project
and i decided to take a
more you know directed approach to
figuring this out and what the first way
that you
the first thing that you need to do to
fix something is understand it
so let's take a look at the commodore 64
circuit board
and kind of break it down now there's
lots going on
you can ignore all those little like
chocolate chip cookie type things
those little capacitors and the other
like passive components on the board
and we can focus on some of the more
interesting chips
on the top left we have io there's our
two identical chips
and they are basically peripheral
controllers
next to them we have a series of roms
they store things like
the basic interpreter the kernel that
basically provides low level
functionality to the rest of the system
specific routines uh a rom chip that
basically just has the character data so
like the actual
text that you see when you type
the cpu that's really important we also
have the sid chip
that we mentioned before below that the
pla
the the ram over to the bottom left of
course we've got a cartridge connector
and the power section of the board
and in the middle we have like the video
section so you can kind of see
that these different components of the
board
of the computer you know live in their
own little regions
and if we think about that the physical
layout of the board
we can kind of map that to the schematic
and so now we don't need to
understand the whole schematic in order
to
you know attack this fix we can
maybe take a more directed approach um
and we can focus on just the information
that's important to us at that time
now i don't have any specific i don't
have any uh
specific like diagnostic equipment for
the commodore 64. although it does exist
so i didn't necessarily know that for
instance all my ram was working and that
all my roms
you know still were returning valid data
i did know that my pla should be working
because i had replaced it
um so i decided to first focus on the
video
circuit we knew that we were seeing this
weird like colored dots
like what is that all about so let's
zoom in on that this is the video region
of the board normally this would have
been covered with like an rf shield
but none of us have x-ray vision and i
don't have an x-ray display and i don't
think you do either
so like we have to take that thing off
and we can see that on the circuit board
now you can't see them in this picture
but these chips are all labeled
and so that's really useful for finding
out where they exist on the circuit
so u19 uh this is i believe the vic 2
chip
and so its role is to generate video
signal but it needs some help
from this little baby chip u31 u31
is a technically a dual voltage
controlled oscillator
its job is to take a clock signal of a
certain frequency
and a clock signal is kind of just like
a beating drum i am not beating with any
particular rhythm
but use your imagination and so
u31 wants to take this particular clock
signal and slow it down
and output that slowed down signal
on its pin pin six
this clock signal is denoted
on the schematic and all the other dot
all the other clock signals that are
relevant to this area of the circuit
are also noted and
we can use this information to our
advantage uh
thankfully i know i'm in a privileged
position to be able to afford
an oscilloscope which is a relatively
expensive tool
but these days you can actually get them
for a whole lot cheaper
and that's a great thing so i took my
oscilloscope and i started probing
around
i measured the master clock signal and
that looked fine
and i then measured these pin six output
on this u9
on this u31 pin six
it's supposed to be 8.1818 megahertz
um but it's not not on my system
i had this really messy signal this is
not what you want to see
and i knew this chip must be bad so
i bought a replacement very fortunate
that these things are still
for sale i didn't have to get one from
another system
and so i installed it still a black
screen but
not a black screen with crazy dots just
a solid black screen
and so that got me thinking okay well
the video seems to be good
let's see if the rest of the system is
operating
now how can we do that well
there are various tools that you can use
like you could use a multimeter
and try and see like okay what is the
what are the various logic levels of
these particular pins but
that's not really the right tool for the
job i use this thing called a logic
probe
i'm going to kind of back and forth on
my slides here but
just bear with me this logic
logic probe allows you to
really easily determine if a given
signal is a logical high or a logical
low
and if you put it on something like a
ram chip on like the address lines
you could see that if you're getting
alternating between low and high really
fast this tool will make like a little
buzzy sound if it's low or high
and it also give you these little
indicators
and so if you see activity like on the
cpu bus or on like the ram
you can kind of be certain that
the cpu is doing something and i wasn't
seeing that behavior
what i was seeing though is that this
signal called
reset was being held
low on my system now what does that mean
what is reset well if you
consider a computer that's turned off
and then you
turn it on well how do you
how do you guarantee that the various
components
in the computer are going to be you know
orchestrated properly and how can it the
system initialize
well you need to have a ground state you
need to have a known
good state to progress from
and so the reset signal is the
the tool for the job if you can generate
a reset signal when the computer turns
on
you say okay well for the first
you know half or one second after
turning on the machine
send a reset signal out and all the
other chips will get this reset signal
and they'll know
to to do whatever they need to do
internally
and then we can turn off that reset
signal and
let the magic happen the kick starts off
all the rest of the the
booting process and on my system
this was not happening every single chip
had the reset signal
held low so they were constantly in this
state
of trying to reset and that's no bueno
so if we take a close look at the reset
signal up the reset schematic
section of the schematic we can see u20
here
which is this chip on the left and we
can see u8 here which is this chip on
the right
556 indicates that this is a 556
timer chip and don't really have time to
get too much into those
but these chips can be used for
generating all sorts of cool signals
in this case the configuration of the
556 timer
is set up in such a way that after a
power is applied
it will generate um a quick blip
for the reset to occur and it
passes that reset signal over to u8
which is a
an inverter chip which kind of takes
like a thumbs up and turns into a thumbs
down or a logical high to a logical low
um and the specific specifics of why
that works the way it does is
again out of scope but basically this
system
was not working the way it should this
reset signal was never being turned off
and so i knew by
my using my logic probe that the 556 end
of the system
was working i could see that for a
little while
the reset signal was being applied
properly and then being turned off
but if you follow the output of the 556
over to the input of the u8 with a logic
probe
you can see the signal and then when you
look at the output
you can see the signal and the output on
pin 8 here was just
constantly low and so that was my say
that was my sign that i need to replace
this chip
so i replaced this chip and again i'm
not going to show the video
but here you can see me uh right after
the computer is turned on
uh we have a logical low being output so
all the chips in my computer
get that little signal and a brief
second later
it goes to high and
that's kind of reverse from what you
might think but if you
um if you just uh give me a little faith
you can know that this fixed
the system here you can see my extremely
messy
uh setup at home i have a lot of video
game consoles i really like games
play them uh when i can and
i was so pleased to hear this uh to see
this i
did not hear it because unfortunately my
sid chip is still dead
but um everything's working
i wanted to talk a little bit more about
preservation and reverse engineering
because that's really important to
keeping these old systems alive and i
know i'm running a little over time so
i'm just going to whiz through this
there's folks doing really amazing stuff
dissolving chips
in acid and imaging them and learning
how they work
at a super low level and we're using
this knowledge to create modern
replacements of those custom chips that
i said had no replacements
well now we have modern replacements and
that's fantastic
fortunately for the world at large you
don't even need to have this
original hardware anymore the folks at
the internet archive are doing a great
job
archiving the software and providing
emulators that you can just run in your
browser
a project that i'm really fascinated by
is the mr fpga project
which uses really
cool technology to re-implement
various computers and game systems in
hardware
which is really cool and
that's it thank you so much i just want
to you know
take a moment to say thank you to all
the essential workers
they've always been essential it's just
they haven't been properly recognized
for that
you can find me on twitter matt clawson
thank you so much bang bang khan